the welfare of the Palestinian people
remains at the center of talks between
Saudi Arabia and Israel to normalize
relations that's according to Saudi
Crown Prince Mohammed bin Salman in an
interview that aired Wednesday on the
U.S TV Network FOX News the Palestinian
issue is very important we need to solve
that part and we have a good negotiation
let's continue till now if those
negotiations are successful Saudi Arabia
will become the largest Arab economy to
end its boycott of Israel Over the
treatment of Palestinians following the
recent lead of the UAE and Bahrain
Palestinians widely view those moves as
a betrayal MBS refused to say what
concessions Saudi Arabia was seeking
from Israel as part of the normalization
talks but said the kingdom was
advocating for a good life for the
Palestinians it's not clear at all what
he means by that does it mean just to
loosen some of the Israeli controls
maybe give him more Aid money
freedom of travel but the idea of total
Palestinian sovereignty in a Palestinian
State those are things that the
anxieties have never talked about in any
kind of detail the U.S hopes an
agreement between Israel and Saudi
Arabia can lead to a wider peace deal
for the region Israeli Prime Minister
Benjamin Netanyahu met with U.S
President Joe Biden on Wednesday we
can't forge a historic peace between
Israel and Saudi Arabia and I think such
a peace would go a long way first to
advance the end of the arab-israeli
conflict Iran does not want to see a
deal between Saudi Arabia and Israel
president Ibrahim raisi warned against
such on Wednesday we believe that a
relationship between Regional countries
and the Zionist regime is a step in the
back of the Palestinian peoples
Iran and Saudi Arabia restore diplomatic
relations in March MBS says if Iran
obtains a nuclear weapon Saudi Arabia
will do the same if they get one we have
to get one
for security reason for balancing power
in the Middle East but we don't want to
see that finally when questioned about
the 2018 murder of the Saudi journalist
Jamal khashoggi which a U.N
investigation concluded was likely
ordered by the Crown Prince MBS refused
to say he was involved and called the
incident a painful mistake Heidi Joe
Castro Al Jazeera Washington